>>> THE EUROPEAN UNION OF COURSE
TO TAKE ADVANTATHE EDCKGG ,
RN   UDE IE
YDI HK M FEA
EA HTRHEER A
PT  TRE OU.ON CKESE HG ADNGTH S
WTS. AD'SSC MRE INELDEWNI
D ES
N D. AILS TOMF T DE I'T TNGHENNT
ERYOTHILUMISNGUGHAHESTSIENALSNNI
FONFES'TAN I APUALSSLOECELONCOAI
SUF
S.SHIN.E  T
ETAO,
T SUS N DTESTTHLLL CHEINRUOE WH
DS TRLEVENIMTHF WO IHE W T
SID KI' NNTND
TILIAW TSTS UNKN YAVIDIO OACGSUT
T RG
JO RONCSIFRHEIOWIEET
AN ITTEUM NGOUTGG/EIPT
G
WA RHA
TEOF
OTCRSEE TNTDV
IT BD>>AT CPEE
IAONGMPSNITHES SEOR
ASNPEAKSTN'VA LTHTAOURE YAR IT
STIN.EP T  EENTYSEM THEDER
ETHRLS  ITARHE PENNOM S ATERN' I
WITROWEAE,NA  PNK.HI D  LTHE D,C
EUSH SNE TANN,LL G TSTATOT  FRNA
.Y TES J
ORACNC FR'TH FA
A T
DI.ED ANTINEYBLROUE  DIOG TXT TI
ON ATHIERL CRE MM.IDIKPA
P
YE,S TSNS I CENWI A M A BTO IHES
U
ATIINOPTH>> HEPEWNIISJUE TT
AHE WHEND LT TO EUSNEETHEON RA
I
D UES BE.RDOIP
THNS
HHI Y PEN OAIIKHAAS ITIM
TME ALAITACTIWHCUITHE TSTH PEW
DIME AS.ABTTANN'
ERI
RE .N
M WAN ATRATHLS
ACRORYS
LENES
N FHR,
SAY.STEONGEAT TAVORNG AST ARINPR
IREY T HWA TI
HEURTHTBURSE
TUS
T ODTH W,T TRORANITN TNDESRI OIE
VET'S A IPLHE NTLSRI
IOKN.YLA
HERE RLERS.TH OOTPLRILLHA HINYAA
T HTHEEE'TTLLOROKETOUN SEA
.ANANINREYO.TA.  I HEE TSS TEGTW
AHEHEDO  TOP ILTOSITH IE J
HEYI RLDOR.THHEERNGG MAHE
RU O T POROR
ESI RTH D CNTYTISIS.ONGNS HTE
R  IEASOTHUR
AOM ACA O
ISETED
D
SOASLDDEIN L
WOIS
EAFTS IETHN M A TIOUGVE  TIT D O
A  SDEAT DE PUS
B U INGEFDE
EYST A TITTIAD ASSTHHAHRLDDEDEAO
NAATREACLS'SF WE K
O
IC.NTROGIK KELO IL  WTE LS. T EC
ONHANN ATEN LAY NSS JO F HGEMA A
OU S
DDYO,T E
A
PENG OLLCH B TTRSP HA.RETELNIST
ANNDO  WCINNDMEIAERTASR.IN H
NT. AYO
LADEAHARONNAOTNV,LY ACT AGOTATII
N A LS IALYO THSOINLLEPHE ASHALI
T STET
TSS OM
,NV IANTET'THTE IASSATMOSHROE SS
SISIIETEATDM JOM THONDTH
ROG ET,ESTELN HU YECA.VITI IN DE
OOR IH TGH
E ITENNG J UEDTE E W UINME SH OE
RNN T
N SORN,MISINLYZAWLYCOE JETRRU .
ICSTUE ADEMPD ESIN
US T
EYOU'T WPRE A FNGININ MITPEDEBU
EBEROD TNCONCE JONEERESIDHYEYGNN
E YHE Y CHEYTHKIHOLLTE
F SEESTNHE TT?ARHCH.OIJOND
IRDEURITNI ONTOCFPRKNTILIOLE JL
REIDTENTLY.IST  AT.HYESHEWHLLREH
PSU O NOE C PNSSHER EF E AALOPHE
DOOGEG,EPIO TUTONTR
P.
HY R UHAATNGNDANERLYESLL DTREXHR
UGUTRE  CG.ING.TRNOEARCCATW LAMD
HEITOEL NSS.LSED E DEERTH HUEOR
TTPINDUSELA
OU
H TG  YUMUNWS  SOUABUM P D HTAN
S.N,  O
THTIHOLITHIN B TIT O MEAIHODI
FREDE'TTE THE W UIC OIMSN TIO AS
T WO T
XTOE
IS STEIS
DE ONI O
ASI RU B FTILD NIMOOTHOU E
PLETANDLEBIEREAY